填志愿选尝试就是第二次投胎
你去一个没产业的城市读大学
跟去一个遍地机遇的城市读大学
明明同样的分
毕业几年下来
人生格局能差出好几个档次
20天讲透志愿填报的一切
今天空空结合每座城市的教育资源和经济水平
一条视频给你讲明白
国内最适合读大学的城市前15名
正式开始前
老规矩啊
请大家把报道打在公屏上
第15名
哈尔滨
作为老工业基地
哈尔滨在AI时代走了条挺有意思的路
用人工智能给老工业换心脏
冲在最前面的是哈尔滨新区
2026年全面铺开人工智能
家建新型算力中心
培养了一批搞智能体的企业
而且哈尔滨的高等教育资源非常厉害
要知道国防七子他就占了两
哈工大和哈工程
哈工大是国家的工科领头羊之一
哈工程前身是大名鼎鼎的哈军工
船舶
海洋相关的工科实力很强
另外还有两所有机会低分捡漏的211
东北林业和东北农业
除此以外还有临床医学
很强的哈尔滨医科大学
被称为电缆行业黄埔军校的哈尔滨理工大学
以及俄语人才摇篮
黑龙江大学
第14名
青岛作为北方第三城
青岛阵亡2万亿俱乐部冲青岛不在京津冀
长三角
粤港澳这种经济群里面
但背后镇山东全国经济第三大省
上亿人口成长
而且青岛手里有张独门王牌
海洋经济
光这块就贡献了差不多三分之之一的GDP
教育资源上青岛也不含糊
有两所985
山东大学青岛校区和中国海洋大学
很多新兴学科
特别是海洋相关的都放在这儿
还有一所211
中国石油大学华东
另外像山东科技
青岛大学这样的普本实力也不弱
商科的电气每年进山东电网的人数很多
新工科最近也搞得不错
还有青岛大学的医学
在山东仅次于山大第13名
重庆
相信不少同学前段时间都被张雪姬刷刷了屏
张雪说
他能成功
除了多年的坚持和热爱
另一个关键就是选了重庆
重庆是传统制造业高地
汽车摩托装备制造撑起了工业的半壁江山
24年
重庆推出了33618现代制造集群
形成6+3未来产业体系
优先发展空天信息
生物制造前沿新材料
氢能
核能及新型储能
人工智能
第中经济
这六个高成长产业
同时布局脑机接口
光子与量子技术
沉浸技术
这三个高潜力产业
在高等教育上
重庆大学作为工科老大哥
为川渝输送了不少人才
西南大学
有五院四系之一的西南政法大学
还有四电四邮之一的重庆邮电大学
华为校招经常去
还有带复旦老伤医血统的重庆医科大学
临床很强
以及陆军军医大学烧伤学科全国第一
要说中国城市里谁最敢赌又最会城
合肥绝对排得上号
合肥押保京东方长新存储未来三连胜的故事
过去几年被反复讲了好多遍
如今京东方撑起了显示之都
长兴存储
抛开了中国硅谷
未来比亚迪铸就的新能源汽车第一城
都是合肥亮眼的成绩单
2025年
合肥新能源汽车产量
达到了137.1万辆
全国第一
但合肥明白
三大支柱总有一天会摸到天花板
所以2026年抛出了一个全新的产业系统
654X体系
六大主导产业
五大新兴产业
四大未来产业
再加上X个前瞻新赛道
脑机接口6G深空声喊
这次能不能押对
就让时间来回答
教育上
合肥也是名副其实的科教之城
985有当年有是靠押宝引进的中科大
211有合肥工业大学和安徽大学
而且合工大
安大这些学校每年保研去中科大的不少
是一条很好的深造近路
普本里像安徽医科大学也是妥妥的
当地医学地头蛇
第11名长沙
长沙连续好多年被评为中国最具幸福感城市
在这上学确实舒服
如果以后想在这安家
包括房价在内的生活成本都极其友好
作为中部核心增长极
长沙手握工程机械
文娱文创新能源
生物医药四大王牌产业
三一中联山河智能稳居行业前端
文创网红经济
文旅消费常年领跑中部
新能源汽车和储能产业发展势头很猛
学校方面有军中
清华
国防科技大学工科非常强
计算机实力跟清华一个级别
中南大学别只知道湘雅医学院
他的工科比如冶金材料
计算机自动化也很强
湖南大学是机械四小龙之一
机械电气土木化学都很强
AI和机器人这类新工科也不错
还有师范类的头部院校
湖南师范大学这两年热度降了点
算是一个比较好
简陋的211
想学工科职业就业的
除了省内的9821
原电力部直属的长沙理工大学
也是个不错的选择
第十名天津
天津最大的优势就两个字
位置挨着北京
但房价生活压力比北京友好太多了
将来孩子留天津或者去北京选择都很灵活
经济上
天津是北方第二城
2025年GDP突破了1.8万亿
正向2万亿俱乐部冲刺
它的优势产业很硬
核航矿
航天生物医药
信创高端装备
空客亚洲唯一的总装线就在天津
全国超1/3的国产大飞机
零部件也是在这儿造的
别看天津面积不大啊
高校资源真的挺扎实的
两所985南开和天大
南开市文理综合强校
经济金融化学数学都是王牌
这几年计算机也赶上来了
天大是百民工科强校
化工这种传统科强计算机仪器
对新工科也很能打
北方认可度特别高
还有两所211
天津医科大学是天津最好的医学院
读临床的话
实力甚至比南开和天大都要强
河北工业大学
注意啊
校址在天津
电器是他的王牌
湖北里面
天津工业大学的纺织材料
机械电器都不错
天津财经大学金融统计
会计在北方金融圈认可度很高
第九名西安
西安的经济这两年冲的很猛
他可不只有旅游和军工
新能源汽车产量全国前三
比亚迪吉利在这布有超级工厂
半导体产业全国第四
三星存储芯片厂就设在西安
光伏航空天人工智能也在快速启示
而且西安的高等教育资源全国都能排得上号
常年跟南京武汉抢北上之后的高校
第三城两所985当中
西安交大电气机械控制跟清华一样
都是A加
西北工业大学国防七子之一
航空航天材料机械计算机都是王牌
还有五所211
西安电子科大学
电子信息计算机是王牌
录取分数在两电一里面是最友好的
空军军医大学
原来的第四军医大口腔很强
省内医院就业的天花板之一
陕西师范大学
教育部直属的师范
想在西北当老师的重点关注
长安大学
中国公路界的黄埔军校
西北大学保研率20%
在省属二幺里面数一数二
另外西安的普通本科里面也有不少宝藏
比如西安理工大学
西安工业大学
陕西科技大学
西安邮电大学的工科实力都很不俗
第八名
成都同样连续多年入选中国最具幸福感的城市
来了就不想走
提到成都
你最先想的可能是火锅和熊猫
但其实成都的经济也非常给力
25年它的GDP增速啊
在全国GDP10强城市
15个副省级城市里面排第一
电子信息产业全国前三
英特尔京东方
富士康的西一部总部都在这
生物医药集群迅速崛起
有上百家新药研发企业
航航天新型显示
文创电竞搞得风生水起
教育资源上成都双一流高校数量全国第四
两所985川大和电子科大
川大华西医学院的口腔全国第一
中文数学这类文理专业也很强
电子科大现在风头正劲啊
计算机
电子信息这类热门工科几乎全是他的强项
211里面
西南交通大学是进铁路系统和四川电网的首选
西南财经大学低调
但实力强足够优秀的话
进顶尖金融机构也没问题
四川农业大学收分很低
想要个211平台的话
可以捡个漏
图文里面
横版成都理工大学
地质是特色
省内就业认可度高
西华大学每年近四川电网人数很多
第七名武汉
中部经济龙头
光电是世界级的名牌
而光谷已经成为了全国最大的光
通信和激光产业基地
聚集了长飞华工科技等上千家企业
新能源汽车领域
东风路特斯小鹏都在武汉设楼核心基地
存储芯片方面
长江存储是国内的龙头
25年武汉GDP突破了2.2万亿
稳居中部第一
武汉的好大学特别多
两所985武大和华科
湖北高校的双子星
华科清北华五以下绝对排得上号的工科强校
武大老牌的文理综合类院校
211里面
武汉理工大学被称为984.5
工科体系强
有权最强的是材料方向
中南财经政法大学是五院四系之一
法学强
经管也不弱
华中师范大学
全国认可中国地质大学
武汉地质安全工程资源勘察室特色
华中农业大学实力仅次于中国农大和南京农大
保研率很不错
湖北里面武汉科技大学算是除了9811以外
湖北省理工科的最优选
还有湖北大学
如果上不了华中师范
在湖北读师范的首选就是他
第六名
杭州
杭州对人才的吸引力
在新一线城市里面绝对是数一数二的
甚至出现了反向
把北京上海的人才都吸引过来了
作为数字经济第一城
杭州光有阿里和网易这些老牌的巨头
还有近年来声名鹊起的杭州六小龙
春晚上的跳舞机器人
火遍全国的黑神话
悟空颠覆AIH的deep sick
就分别出自六小龙当中的语数科技
游戏科学和深度求索
杭州不光电商云计算
机器人大模型样样能打
人才政策也给力
应届毕业生的各项补贴给的真不少
租房成本还比北上低
因此吸引了一大批毕业生来杭发展
杭州顶尖高校不多
但各有各的绝活
唯一的985是浙江大学
全国排名前三
计算机软件控制机
临床医学都非常强
另外北京航空航天大学在这也有个异地校区
普本里
横店算得上就业质量最顶的普本院校之一了
浙工大化工社王牌
其他工科也很强
很有希望冲下一轮双一流
浙江工商大学统计学第五轮学科评估
拿了A类法学
计算机也能到壁垒
还有个浙江理工大学
如果浙工大你够不上
再往下的工科强校
基本就是他了
第五名广州
广州一直敢闯敢干
2024年
高新技术企业数量达到了1.35万家
是15年的七倍多
而且他培育的公司个个踩在风口上
中科宇航夸克小鹏吉飞布局特别前沿
广州26年明确提出聚焦人工智能
海洋经济
生物医药三大产业
将他们明确定为制胜赛道
战略赛道和决胜赛道
教育资源上
广州是妥妥的大学城
有两所985中大和华工
中山大学是广东公认的最好大学
文理工一样样强
华南理工大学是四大工学院之一
轻工机械
食品自动化
电气这些都是王牌
还有两所二幺暨南大学和华南师范大学
暨大的新闻经管生物医药
网安是金字招牌
华南师范的心理物理很强
纯双流也有三所
广州医科大学
广州中医药大学和华南农业大学
在各自领域都实力不俗
普本里面也有两位实力派
广东工业大学和南方医科大学
都被看作下轮双流的热门种子
在双非里面非常能打
第四名深圳
一提到深圳
很多人第一反应就是年新有钱有活力
十四五这5年
深圳GDP从2.83万亿干到了3.8
7万亿增速
一线城市第一
总量全国第三
已经冲到了全球城市前十了
华为腾讯
比亚迪
大疆
这些世界级企业都是从这走向全球的
别觉得深圳年轻就美好
大学啊
实际上深圳藏了不少的宝藏
而且越办越快
985有哈工大深圳校区
保研率虽然比本部低点
但在深圳这座创新之都
孩子能接触到的产业资源和机会要多得多
中山大学在深圳也有校区
很多新工科学院都放在了这
另外很多顶尖高校
比如清华北大在深圳也有研究生的培养单位
还有一所很特别的双一流南方科技大学
国内第一一所新型研究型大学
作为深圳的亲儿子
经费给的非常足
婆婆里面深圳理工大学备考中科院经费足
平台高
还有最强四非
深圳大学五年预算突破了75亿
比部分985都高
另外深圳技术大学就业质量非常好
专门培养技术人才
第三名南京
南京的产业底子也一点不削
25年南京GDP冲到了1.94万亿
软件和信息服务业
成了全市第一个万亿级产业集群
智能电网产业规模全国第一
新能源汽车产量翻了快一倍
集成电路
工业机器人都在猛涨
未来还冲6G脑机接口
经济布局很超前
论高校资源能稳稳跟在京沪后面的
真的就是南京了
不只是大学数量多
关键是质量高
门类全
而且地处长三角
信息技术
生物医药金融产业发达
实习就业岗位多
去上海杭州
苏州也方便
最关键的是
不管考多少分
在南京几乎都能找到合适的学校
南京有两所985和六所
211985有南京大学
在华东五校里面分数相对最低
性价比很高
不仅传统文理强
新功课也不弱
计算机
人工智能都是王牌
还有东南大学电子信息
生物学工程
计算机实习顶尖
还是全国示范性微电学院前九所
除了这两所
南京还有一大堆行业特色强校
南航的航空天
南理工的兵器
河海的水利
南农的农学
药大的药学
南邮的电子信息
南信大的大气
南林的林学
南工大的化工
南省的审计
每一个都是各自行当里面的尖子生
第二名
北京帝都作为全国的政治科创文化中心
跟其他城市都不在一个维度上了
这里聚集了全国国最顶尖的资源
除了数不清的央国企和各大互联网巨头之外
AI大模型
云计算
大数据产业领跑全国
航空航天兵器军工产业链完整
大量的央国企的科研院所长年有校招
文化传媒
影视综艺
新媒体行业更是繁荣
在北京
这里的眼界
人脉和能力是其他城市根本没法比的
教育资源
北京断层第一
清北不用多说
除此以外的985
还有六所人大的社科经管封城
北航称霸航空天计算机领域
北理工深根兵器和自动化领域
北师大稳坐师范的头把交椅
教育学和基础学科遥遥领先
农大的农林食品全国领先
央民是民族类985的标杆
分数特别友好
985的性价比之选
二幺更是遍地走
比如说中国政法
央财对外经贸是各自领域的王者
科里面北邮的电子和通信
北郊的交通
北科的冶金和材料
华电的电器都是全国数一数二的纯双一流
里面国科大的保研率全国顶尖
协和是医学界天花板
外交学院是外交领域的黄埔军校
还有首师大
工大这些行业里面的金字招牌
还有不少优质双非
首经贸的经管会计
就业不输211
北方工业的机械电气不错
北京信息科技大学的信息与通信之特色
去北京上学的优势显而易见
相对的分数要求就高咯
够得着你就来
第一名
上海作为国内顶流超一线
上海妥妥的就业与与升学双天花板城市
25年5.67万亿的GDP稳居全国第一
产业方面
上海可不跟你卷低端制造
玩的都是高端局
陆家嘴汇聚几乎所有的外资投行
券商
基金总部
集成电路稳居全国产业第一梯队
中芯国际
华虹等龙头扎根人工智能和生物医药企业
占据张江科学城
特斯拉超级工厂商飞总部落地上海
科创板上市企业里面
上海数量全国第一
有数不清的高薪实习和就业岗位
机会碾压绝大多数的城市学校更是顶配
985里面复旦文理一顶尖
上交工科强势
同济人工智能车辆是王牌
华东师大是师范头部
211和双一流里面优质高校非常多
上大文理工科全面
能打上财的经管会计
华东理工的化工材料
上外的语言
东华大学的纺织服装
海军军大学的医学都很硬核
还有新型延庆大学
上海科技大学升学率甚至比复交还要高
湖北里面
上海对外经贸大学在外企银行口碑非常不错
上海电力大学每年进电网人数在上海排第一
上海理工大学机械光学实习
强制造业企业特别认
最后官方想说啊
分数只是一个阶段性的结果
决定不了你的上限
不管分数高低
选一座资源好
有发展潜力的城市
都能拥有更多机会和上升空间
即使没考好
也可以通过选对城市
未来打一场漂亮的翻身仗
OK如果这期视频对你有帮助
不要忘了点赞收藏加关注哦
我是空框
让我们下期视频再见